[Music]
in the battleground state of michigan
democratic candidate joe biden was
joined by his ex-boss
former u.s president barack obama a
first for the biden campaign as they
fight for victory in michigan
where trump won by a razor thin margin
four years ago
a final campaign push in a battleground
state
obama didn't hold back
i understand this is a president who
wants full credit for the
economy he inherited
and gets zero blame for the pandemic he
ignored
but the job doesn't work that way
tweeting at the tv doesn't fix things
making stuff up doesn't make people's
lives better you've got to have a plan
biden drove home the words of his former
boss
we choose unity over division
science over fiction and yes we choose
truth over lies
so it's time to stand up take back our
democracy
we can do this we're so much better than
this
we can be who we are at our best the
united
states of america hi folks trump
supporters and good spirits ahead of a
rally on halloween
the president won the crucial state of
pennsylvania in the last election
and he's hoping for a repeat for many
voters
there's much at stake
you know this battle isn't democrat
versus republican
this is um the dark against the light
it's the good versus evil and this is
this is a monumental election because of
that not because it's donald trump and
joe biden
it's because it is a way of life that we
have known in this country for decades
and it's it's at stake right now
[Music]
president trump spoke of unity as the
nation braces for election
day we are one movement
one people one family and one glorious
nation
under god and together with the
incredible people of pennsylvania
we have made america powerful again our
military our military
campaigning enters its home stretch as a
record number of americans
are predicted to turn out
dw reporter peter rolidahl joins me now
for more on all of this peter first
question is why are they barnstorming
these particular states
well because of these states like
michigan pennsylvania florida are
well not so much florida but definitely
michigan and pennsylvania are states
that trump won by racial thin margin
back in 2016. and
without these states it's hard to see
how he
really comes back and wins his election
uh you know
there are also states where biden
continues to hold the lead
the race has been fairly stable
in uh biden's favor for the past weeks
and months almost
even in states like georgia north
carolina we're starting to see
you know traditionally very conservative
republican states
where the demographics really have
shifted become younger
voters of color that are really not very
big fans of trump
um so we're starting to see their shift
in biden's favor
um that set though biden's lead is
narrowing
in some key states like florida uh north
carolina is still very tight
so you know it you know frankly i hear
you talk and i'm i'm i know people
listening to you are probably seeing the
ghost of 2016.
because people were saying that hillary
clinton was up too
and then in the waning days it started
at titan yeah so
there must be some of that on the minds
of the democrats as well
there's a lot of that there's absolutely
a lot of that we we have been seeing a
lot of reports
um also of you know democrats you know
especially
you know even seasoned pollsters and and
campaign strategists
obviously no one is going to rule out a
trump comeback
um and part of the way to try to make
that not happen i'm sure
is bringing out the big guns i mean
today we see barack obama the former
president
out on the campaign trial with bet biden
why is it critical to bring him to that
particular state
well because you know the rust belt uh
michigan wisconsin a lot of these you
know
traditionally that used to be strong
industrial states that have really been
been you know hurt by by
you know global economy a lot of
industry have left that area has been
been drained economically financially
um obama was those states were really
crucial to
obama's victory back in 08 in in 2012.
you know
you might remember in the in the wake of
the financial crisis we saw the auto
industry almost collapsing
he went there helped save the industry
with
joe biden and this is definitely a
reminder of those you know
remember that this is who you voted for
and this who helped save you is
essentially what he was trying to say so
i think
with obama going to those states now
we're seeing
you know them trying to win back a lot
of those
democrats who in 2016 turned around and
went for
and voted for trump and even a lot of
disaffected republicans who hope you
know what
trump as this successful businessman
that a lot of people
thought of him as um he has not been
able to
give that joel to those states that they
were hoping for yeah and his coronavirus
certainly hasn't helped um with 48 hours
now out here
yeah what is the election looking like
byton still continues to hold a
comfortable lead nationally
obviously it will come down to keys days
like pennsylvania like wisconsin like
michigan like florida
biden's road to victory still looks
much broader like the map so he if he
can hold on to
the states that clinton won in 2016
and maybe flip a couple of the states
that
trump won like arizona where biden is
currently up by three points
michigan where biden is currently up by
eight points wisconsin where he's
currently up by eight points
he could still lose big states like
pennsylvania and florida
and still win trump it seems is really
in the battle for his political survival
never will allow to come back
he can still come back but the odds are
definitely looking a lot bleaker than um
than they are for biden his margin of
error is a lot slimmer is what it sounds
like absolutely
peter rolla dolls thank you so much for
that